[Music]
alrighty so today we are going to be
discussing bitcoin
what is it how does it work should you
invest in it this video is sponsored by
our friends at
raycon oh yes these are the best earbuds
on the market we'll get to that a little
bit
later so what is bitcoin some people
think that bitcoin is just a giant scam
some people think that
bitcoin is the wave of the future so we
have people who are pro bitcoin
and we have people who are anti bitcoin
on the pro
bitcoin side of course you have elon
musk very very pro bitcoin you have the
winklevosses
they are very pro bitcoin on the con
side you have people like
peter schiff he's very con on bitcoin
you have michael berry
from the big short he is very con on
bitcoin
to explain what bitcoin is first you
sort of have to understand
what money itself is now i know what
you're thinking well it's it's right
here in my wallet that's what money is
yes that's what a physical dollar is but
what exactly is money supposed to do so
from the earliest times people have
found a way
to convey value to one another in pieces
of exchange that are not actually the
items of exchange let's say that you
have
this guy and this guy loves oranges he
grows oranges for a living right that's
what he grows
and he wants to trade with this guy and
this guy
grows apples for a living okay they
could just trade the apples for the
oranges directly but what if the problem
is
this guy doesn't actually need oranges
or this guy doesn't actually need apples
well
then what they do is they find a
different method of exchange basically
an iou note right and that iou note can
go
in any form right you can have an iou
note that looks like a c shell this is
what many
early cultures did right they'd have an
iou note that was a seashell he doesn't
know how to use the three seashells
then it became that the iou note was
basically done with the value of gold
[Music]
okay so in america and for a long time
in the west the standard for this was
the gold standard that
every dollar that you spent was backed
by a certain amount of gold
it used to be that you could take a u.s
dollar
and you could trade it in at the federal
reserve
and you could get back some gold then
along comes fdr and fdr
severs the value of the dollar in gold
right during the fdr administration
fdr decided that he didn't like that the
american dollar couldn't just be
inflated because see the thing is you
can't just create
extra money when you just create extra
money you're not actually
creating extra underlying value so what
that actually means is that let's say
that the government has a big debt let's
say the government has a debt of
a million dollars well you would say
well they need to come up with a million
dollars in taxes right they need to come
up with value of a million dollars
in order for them to pay back that debt
what governments quickly discovered and
have known for a very long time
is that there's another way to pay off
that million dollar debt and that is to
go in the back room and just print off a
million dollars
and then hand you all that monopoly
money now you may feel screwed and in
fact you will feel screwed and you're
not going to want to do transactions
with that government anymore
but this is one way that governments get
out of their own debt it's one way the
government can spend
without actually having to tax
additionally or to withdraw resources
from an economy so fdr decided he
changed the value of gold arbitrarily he
just decided we're going to inflate the
amount of currency
versus the amount of gold that's out
there okay but the united states wasn't
completely off the gold standard
until 1971 richard nixon decided in the
bretton woods agreement that the united
states would no longer rely on the gold
standard at all and this made the dollar
a fiat currency
a fiat currency is a currency that
doesn't have any underlying value the
dollar is instead
based on the full faith
and credit of the us going all the way
back
seashells were only worth something
because they thought okay well that
farmer he's gonna be able to farm
something
and that iou note is gonna be worth
something after he does his farming the
same way the federal government is
reliant on your full faith and credit in
them
to eventually come up with the money to
pay you back for the amount of money
that you have in your bank account right
that's the way that dollar value is
established is through the full faith
and credit
of the united states okay so all of that
is backdrop to what bitcoin is because
i've just explained how fiat currencies
work
and inherence in there is an explanation
of
why people probably should not trust
fiat currencies so people who have been
looking for a repository of value that
is not dependent on centralized
government
have been looking to other sources for a
long time thanks to the rise of the
digital world
you're using your credit card for
virtually everything right now but
that credit card is predicated on dollar
value for example what if
you could do transactions with pretty
much anyone
and you could do it without having to
refer to the dollar you wouldn't have to
worry about central banks you wouldn't
have to worry
about government blowing up the value of
the currency all
that a bitcoin is is a belief that other
people are going to use the bitcoin
so who created bitcoin supposedly it is
this guy
right here supposedly his name is
satoshi nakamoto now the reason i say
supposedly is because nobody actually
knows who created bitcoin
and supposedly it is this guy who's
supposed to be 40 and from japan
that's kind of awesome because you don't
want to have a centralized guy who
controls all of bitcoin some mastermind
criminal
who actually can inflate bitcoin at any
point and then sell all of his bitcoin
for a bunch of money you want it to be
decentralized that is the purpose
the basic idea of bitcoin is that you
are concerned that this right here the
full faith and credit of the united
states or any government
it doesn't mean anything right what if
you are worried about that what if you
are worried that the government can
simply devalue dollars
well then you need to find another
repository of value so what bitcoin is
is you believe that the currency is
stable enough to be used and enough
people are going to accept the currency
that it has inherent value
instead of you relying on the
government's ability to tax and the
government's ability to stimulate and
the government's ability to print and
take out of circulation instead of
relying on all of those powers you're
relying on the idea that there is
something that is trusted by enough
people that they will use that in the
absence of a government so
you're giving up a certain amount of
faith in the pure unbridled power of
government
in favor of faith in other people
believing in the same iou notes that you
believe in
this is why some people like leadership
like that's a pyramid scheme because
just like any other temporary repository
of value
people could fall out of love with
bitcoin and that's true people could
fall out of love with bitcoin or they
could find
a new version of bitcoin you see new
sort of currencies springing up every so
often so theoretically you could have
people decide you know what
we don't want to use bitcoin anymore or
businesses say we're not going to accept
bitcoin as payment anymore and the value
could theoretically
go to zero that is 100 true it also
happens to be the case
that bitcoin cannot be controlled from
the outside because governments can make
currencies worth zero but governments
don't have the power to make bitcoin
worth zero that is because bitcoin
is not a centralized currency it is a
decentralized cryptocurrency
so that comes with some cost and it
comes with some benefits on the cost
side you cannot rely
on the ability of bitcoin to give you
some sort of hard asset in exchange
for your bitcoin because that doesn't
exist that's not what bitcoin is on the
good side of the ledger you don't have
to worry that the creators of bitcoin
are going to simply inflate the value of
bitcoin or deflate the value of bitcoin
by simply printing
new bitcoin in essence here is sort of
the difference between fiat currency and
bitcoin
fiat currency is a government right
called the us government
and the u.s government decides the value
of the currency
and then that value is promulgated to
all of the other human beings right
these are all the citizens all the
citizens
are out here yay citizen okay and then
we have an unhappy citizen
so the value of the us dollar is decided
by the us government
when it comes to bitcoin it is precisely
the opposite
instead you have a bunch of people out
here
and these people have to decide what
they think bitcoin is worth and because
bitcoin is not
an actual government who's actually
creating the value of bitcoin
instead you have all of these people
investing their own assets
into bitcoin so the definition of value
is incredibly different
the definition of value is coming from
the outside in as opposed to
from the inside out
there are some who say that bitcoin is
worthless it's
not valuable but then there are others
who say that you can trade
bitcoin for something truly incredible
like these raycons the greatest of all
wireless earbuds so here's the thing
raycon
is disrupting the electronics industry
by designing premium wireless audio for
half the price without compromise
they're doing things differently than
the other brands out there from the way
they design their products to the way
they price them
raycon prioritizes their customer
experience from start to finish
raycon offers their wireless earbuds in
a range of fun colors and patterns with
a variety of fit options
no dangling wires no stems the company
was co-founded by ray j celebrities like
snoop dogg mike tyson
and me are obsessed with raycons there's
a sentence you're not going to hear
every day
plus raycon has a 45 day free return
policy raycon earbuds give you six hours
of play time
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass a
more compact design for a comfortable
noise isolating fit if you're trying to
take a break from screens but you don't
want to feel totally unplugged
raycon wireless earbuds those are the
best way to bring your favorite content
with you
wherever you go i mean look at these
babies they are incredible
they fit your ear beautifully so
click the link in the description box or
go to buy recon dot com
shapiro yt to get 15 percent off your
raikon purchase today
now the reason that people call it a
cryptocurrency is because the technology
of bitcoin
the thing that prevents it from being
inflated is that there are a set number
of bitcoins
in circulation a certain number are
being added every year but it's a very
very low number
the bitcoins that are in circulation
cannot be
jacked around with they cannot be
counterfeited and that is because the
crypto technology that is used
in order to encrypt the transactions
right people are using cryptography they
are using actual cryptography in order
to
protect the transactions that take place
and you've heard of this thing called
blockchain but blockchain technology
essentially is every time somebody uses
a portion of bitcoin for a transaction
they're an entire
group of people they are called bitcoin
miners and their job is to simply verify
the transaction
their job is to try and unlock all of
the cryptography
in order to ensure the transaction is
legitimate and to make sure that you
can't use the same cryptocurrency twice
right this is sometimes what people
worry about is that
somebody has a bitcoin and they
simultaneously give the bitcoin to two
different people that can't happen
thanks to blockchain technology so once
a certain number of transactions are
verified
that is called a block
every time the the bitcoin miners
create a block it is added to the
blockchain right
with every block that is added to the
blockchain you are creating a more and
more
unbreakable chain of events and more
faith and credit in the bitcoin
itself which is why it's good right you
can't even understand how these
transactions
are verified but you know that they are
being verified and they're being
verified
in real time over the course of time and
you earn bitcoin for doing this for
participating
in this process so you actually have a
really transparent look into all the
transactions that have been done with
bitcoin so you know that people aren't
screwing around with the currency and
that of course
is the chief promise of bitcoin is that
people are not screwing around with the
currency because again
no one is in control of the bitcoin
there is not a centralized person who
decides how many bitcoins ought to be
issued
there is not a centralized body that
decides whether to inflate or deflate
the currency
and so that means that bitcoin is
entirely reliant on how many people
decide to use bitcoin
this is why bitcoin has gone from
essentially a zero value proposition
what appeared to be people spending
dollars for zero things
and now a bitcoin is worth up to fifty
thousand dollars the answer is the more
people buy into it
the more the bitcoin is worth so in that
way it really is
no different than gold except that gold
is a hard asset and bitcoin
is just a digital asset
one of the things that has happened here
is that you've seen some big companies
like elon musk big believer
in bitcoin his company tesla just bought
1.5 billion dollars in bitcoin what is
he really saying
he's really saying that i believe more
in this value as a repository of value
than in something like a us bond or a us
dollar i believe that this is going to
grow in value as people turn away from
centralized governments and fiat
currencies
in favor of a currency that is not
controlled and not inflatable
by outside parties and as the economy
grows more and more reliance on
government spending
and as people see that governments are
never going to pay back these debts and
that governments are going to continue
to run up those debts people like elon
musk are probably going to do more and
more of this you're going to see more
and more people say okay you know what
i'm going to take my money
and don't feel like investing in gold
because i can't use gold for actual
transactions it's a good repository
value but i can't use it for actual
transactions and instead i'll just put
it in bitcoin because
i can still use it at the local grocery
store and also it happens to hold by
transactional value
so the government has a couple of
worries about bitcoin number one is that
if people start investing in bitcoin
instead of worrying about the us dollar
that means there are fewer people who
are buying bonds theoretically you could
buy this as a holder of value over the
long term
and you're going to do that instead of
buying government debt so the government
can't actually issue
more debt meaning they can't raise more
money to pay for all of the
various projects that they wish to
engage in the other problem for
government is that when you're talking
about a completely digital currency that
is not controlled by them and not
verifiable by them
they are worried about the possibility
of this sort of currency for criminal
use there are a thousand reasons why you
might not want the government to know
how you are transacting business if you
happen to be a libertarian you don't
think it's the government's business
how you transact business or with whom
you transact business if you are
somebody who believes that the
government
is badly motivated and would seek to
crack down on bitcoin holders
for some reason or remove the value of
bitcoin in some nefarious way
the more closely bitcoin is protected
the less government has the power
to do all of that there's always a flip
side of the coin
there is a pirate vibe the reason
there's a pirate vibe is because any
time anybody acts entrepreneurially
outside the auspices of government it
feels like a pirate is doing it we have
just been conditioned to think that way
but these people are not criminals they
are acting outside the scope and
authority
of the government in the sense they are
creating a rival to the government's
main asset which is your full faith and
credit in their system remember
bitcoin goes up when faith in the system
goes down if you have faith in the full
faith and credit of the united states
you're buying bonds
if you don't have faith that the united
states is not going to inflate the
currency you're buying bitcoin right now
cryptocurrencies are exploding
facebook has its own currency you have
pot coin which is pushed by i guess
dennis rodman along with pistachios
or something you have ethereum you have
litecoin you have a bunch of different
types of cryptocurrency anytime there's
a market for
any sort of digital currency there will
be rival digital currencies the question
is which one gains credence in the
marketplace it's why
at the very beginning it takes big
people buying into this sort of stuff to
make a difference in the market for it
right the more elon musks you have
buying into bitcoin the more faith there
is that bitcoin is a real thing so at
the beginning it does appear to be
incredibly volatile whether those
succeed or fail is largely and actually
entirely based on the public
view of whether those things are going
to succeed or fail and this is why so
many people are skeptical of
cryptocurrencies in the first place
but my feeling is that over time
cryptocurrencies particularly ones that
find a place in the market the way that
bitcoin has i think that those are going
to continue to rise
i think as we have less and less faith
in centralized governments and it seems
to me that we are
right now as that happens more and more
i think you're going to see more and
more people
looking to diversify away from fiat
currencies and instead moving into
places like bitcoin for actual safety
and security despite all the talk about
volatility
it may be that in the future the most
volatile forms of currency are the ones
coming
from centralized governments within ax
to grind as opposed to a decentralized
group of people who simply wish
to engage in transactions that hold
their value